Hundreds of millions of users of social networks around the world...
...have completely changed the view of communicating online, building your brand.
It used to be your site being at the center.
It used to be Google. You had to make your site searchable and accessible through search engines.
Now it's all about being shareable.
It's not only about Twitter and Facebook, of course, which are kind of the two main drivers of growth.
It can be professional social networks such as LinkedIn.
It can be other types of sites which you don't expect to be social networks...
...such as YouTube or Flickr.
Videos and pictures can be very, very powerful.
And they are social networks because there are comments,...
...you can get followers and following on Flickr and on YouTube...
...and in so many others.
It can be question and answer sites such as Formspring or Quora.